Oh. Oh yeah.
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to the world of virtual reality.
I finally have my virtual —
*Markimoo garbles*
I finally have my virtual reality set up — all set up and ready to go
which means that I have all the space
that I need to be able to enter the virtual world. Also you may notice, I got no strings to hold me down
Habaa da boo badoo badoo badoo diddly lee dap beep bop barp
I'm gonna be doing a lot of virtual reality, but this is Doom VFR
Now this just came out, and I don't know if it's any good or not.
I'm gonna do...
I played the da- I played- I did my Let's Play of Doom, on u-
Oh...
I did my let's play of doom on ultraviolence, so I don't know if that's gonna be the right approach,
but that's the approach that I'm gonna be taking!
Ooh...
Oh ga- that's- AH!
Hang on!
Robotic voice: ".. . make your commitment today!"
Ooh. Oh, these are... ro-
Hah? Hello?
Ohhh... (Robo-lady:Demonic presence detected)
Yeah, I'm sure about that
Yea, imma- what the hell? Is everything okay?
*stunned silence at sounds of demonic violence happening outside*
Well...
*demonic screeching*
Ah.
Hey!
Robotic female voice: "Demonic presence. Enabling safe levels."
Good to know. Wahoo!
WOOHOO! Uh oh.
That's not a good sound.
Oh shit. Hi.
Hello.
UWAH HEY!
Good god. Hi. Okay. Thank you for that.
Ohhhh... "Main power offline."
Male voice: "Where... am I?"
Ugh
"Oh my God, I'm. I'm dead..."
"But not..."
Oh..."NOT"
Alrighty then
"...must have activated the Cognitive Transfer Protocol."
Oh-
"This hasn't been done since...Hayden..."
Of course-  "Time to get some answers." I knew that. Oh...
Sick sleeps casualties.
"We'll start there."
*Markiplier grunting noises*
"There has to be a combat chassis somewhere." Huh? "That would work."
"Good timing."
That thing? Ohh. "Let's see what this thing can do."
Okay, well, I don't know what's happening. He said the combat chassis proto- oh-ho.
Oh!
Doodly, doodly, doodly!
HERE COMES THE AIRPLANE!
Don't you run from me. Listen, there's one thing I don't like and that's people running for me, okay?
Where are you guys by the way? Am I looking in the right direction?
This is the first thing I've recorded today, so I have no idea if everything is fine or not.
But. Boy I didn't even confirm nothing- ooh.
Oh ah! What did I do? Usually in these, there's a teleport mechanic. Ah!
I understand! Yes, go into the pit. Ah
Ohh
Ooh
Ahh
Okay now this time you're not gonna run from me cuz I'm gonna do one of these maneuvers. Oh. Ungh!
All right fine, I'll use it- ah there we go. I didn't read what it said.
Ahh
Ohh
Ah, that's gonna make me puke. Ah, I get it. Okay. I get it. HA! HOO! HEY! OOH!
Low...
Hi!
Oh, what? "Reading is for nerds the combat chassis is ekoopad with very use weapoons.
Using the whoop and wule you can swootch betwoon your coo-" AAH!
AAH!
I DIDN'T READ!
READING IS FOR NERDS!
HABOOM! Ha ha ha ha
HABANGY! Ha ha ha ha ha
I got you!
Haboink!
Ah. This- ooh "WHEN A DOOMOON IS STOOGERED
FROOM TOOKING ENOOF DOOMOOGE, YOU CAN TOOLEPOOT INTOO OOT"
Why can I teleport in the first place?
AHH! Hey, hey hey. Whahey! Hang on. Oh hey
hey, hey, listen Sally Sue
I ain't take too kindly to your kind of interruptions. I'm gonna go this way now.
Eh. Hello! Oh. I guess I don't have a gun now. "The come back chaboose is oosue oocoopooed with granoodoos Hi-yah, oh...
That was a hefty throw
Uh!
Woah. Ho-ho-ho!
Hang on I got- I got a present for you! Oh come on, okay, real gentle-like.
Pad
I'm so DAAAH. I'm so strong. I- show it up there. Oh, I know. Oh
Jesus I'm so strong! Who knew?
Ah! Ah, ah! Ah! Help! Help, help, help, ah, help! Hey, I'm out.
Ah! Oh
Jesus Christmas, oh. "Use the sheoold boost
aboolity to poosh book dewmans that are surroonding you."
Shield burst!
Nice. BLONK. Nice, okay, alright. Oh oh. Oh.
I don't know what shield burst means, but okay. So I have like a shield or something ooh. Oh hello ohh.
"The oroogoon kushu can upgroode woon of your three abbulu dues."
*laughs*
All right, I'm gonna stop doing that that's officially uh. It's officially gotten annoying hasn't it? Oh wait,
it was always annoying? Oh, my bad. I'm trying to touch it. For some reason
I can't tooch you! Uh-oh. "Return to play area?" Why, what are you gonna do?
What are you gonna do about it, game?
Nothing, that's right. What am I doing? What?
*Markiplier noise*
Okay, I've got a gun. I don't have a gun. Oh!
I point at it. That's what I do. Oh... "Slow motion during teleportation." Well this seems good.
I don't even know what that means, but I'm gonna accept it as my own. Upgrude! Ahh!
Ooh...
Very time slow. Hi-ya!
Alright?
"Weapon OOP groots: the weapon upgrade station allows you to upgrade one of your weapons."
Ah...
I'm dead. I'm dead I died. I'm, I'm dead oh here I am now. I guess I'm not dead ooh.
Excuse me. I got dangly hand. Got a bad case of dangle hand. I'm gonna go this way. Oh! Uh, hmm, uh, hmm.
Let me. Hmm. Let me think about that hmm, that's a...
huludu. Charged energe. Ah, boring. I'm at three round bursts, tighter spell, ah!
I like, I like a tight spread. Everybody knows Markiplier likes a nice tight spread. Oh.
"Congrootulootioons
on complootoon the kumu choosoos to do real!
"Feel free to practice and experiment with your abilities in this room. When you're ready to return to reality, stand on the teleportation pad."
Sure. Okay, ah oh hey. Hey ohh
hey.
Oh. Time slow, huh?
Ha ha!
Wa. Ah! Oh geez oh geez. Ah ye! Oh I see how it be! Okay, alright. Ooh. What are you gonna
do buddy? Miss me! Oh.
Hey hey! Alright. Okay, okay, I get it.
I think I get it. Okay, I got- I got it. I got it. I got I get it. I get it oh.
Male voice: "You need to get the main power online."
Do I?
Ooh.
He said that this hasn't been done since Aiden (Hayden), which I can only assume means that
they're talking about
Aiden the like director of all this and the CEO of the UAC and all that jazz, which is fascinating. How you doing?
How you doing buddy? You okay? Is that my body? I'm assuming I'm in a big metal chassis.
Like, uh, like we had at, you know, the other place hoh!
Well, I got it. I'm a lumbering behemoth.
Ooh. Okay, ah man. That is gonna make me vomit.
Ooh. Hey! Hi da oh...
Ah-ha! Ah-huh!
I got it. Guys, I got it! Doom guy! I'm a hero! Look at me! "Eliminate the de-" .oh
"This should be fun." Should it be? I died once, so I don't know if I want to do it again ooh...
Hello! Hey!
Who's there? Huh? Oh.
Well, they're all dying without me, so I guess I'm fine. Okay.
Whoa what the hell? They're just fighting each other! Hey hey hey ow! Jeezums, that hurt like a bastard!
Whoa he's got no body. Oh, where did you go? Come on! Come on let me let me get that one.
Let me- please. I- aww. I wanted it so badly!
Who's behind me? No one? Okay. Oh AH!
Too close, too clo- ah! Too close!
Jesus, that guy was not fun. I could tell. By the cut of his jib I could tell. Ooh ah. Dodged ya! Ooh.
Okay, alright. This is a little more manageable. Ow! Uh-oh that ain't good. I'm alAHHH!
I might die, I might I might die actually ooh. Ah!
Woah, waHEYYY wa
okay, I- wow.
What- where is my hand?
Where am I? Oh there I am. That was hard. That was legitimately hard. I mean number one, it's different experience being in real life.
Quote-unquote virtual reality, having to use my hands and legs and such.
I'll get it. Okay. Alright. Let me try the poostal. There we go. Get him from a distance,
you know how it be. Time to not suck! Peak around corners! Shoot from a distance!
Uh-oh. I've got the stratagem!
Okay, or do I just let them fight, and just. Ha! Well this is a lot easier, but a lot less fun.
Yeah, I'm bored. Okay. I'm gonna go back to the shotgun. Oh yeah.
Oh get some! Oh you want some? I have some. Here, have some. Whoa, I've got a surplus of it.
Oh wow that- that hurts so bad! Why does that hurt so bad? I know I'm on a high difficulty but good god!
Something tells me- oh what did you expect? Okay. Thank you. Yeah. I don't know honestly. Where we going here? Huh?
What are we doing? Ooh.
Alright.
Whoa okay all right. No, then I do a sissy throw? Oh god. Oh god. Oh god. Shit. Ow! God damn
you! Are- AH! God damn it! Ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow. There we go! Got it. It is really hard to move.
AHHH!
Where are you? Oh god. That's my grenade! I'm gonna die. Here we go. Oh jeez oh jeez ah gee willikers!
Oh, I did it! Ah!
Look at me!
Being all skilled in the such as. Okay, where am I going? That way. Alright. Okay. I see. Ooh...
Ohhh...
Ooh. Woah.
Male voice: "... facility status."
Hey Dan. "...an argent energy transfer station has been activated." Ooh!
Hello wow- "...that argent reserve station created a new portal."
*random Markimoo noises*
"If that portal isn't closed, this facility will be overrun."
Uh. A goochy, goochy goo. *Markimoo noises* "... is broken."
"You're going to need that to get around."
Uh-huh. *kissy noises*
Oh no. Oh
Whatever your name, bleh, is that turns into the Spider Queen? Oh.
I never realized how beautiful your eyes were. Oh, oh.
Samuel Hayden, oh, you're so big and strong.
*more kissy noises*
Oh. But our love can never be. We're both robos from the waist down.
*even more kissy noises*
Oh. But our love can transcend robotics hmm muah.
*more kisses again...*
Hey guys
Room for a third in here? Eh, I feel bad about that one. Hey guys! Room for a third in here?
No, okay, that makes no sense all right. I'm done here. Alright
what else we got? Ah. Oh! Over there! Hang on wait. Look at you just look at you.
*kiss* Hello.
Let me get a look at dat ass. Yep.
That is an ass. Huh, you- you co- come here, come here you. Let me get a look at dat ass. Oh.
Underwhelming at best. Alright, doom guy! Hmm.
Insubstantial. All right okay. You guys have fun. I'm out of here. Where am I going all right. Let's go in there- "... need to find the key."
Fuck!
Well, this can't be right
"... bet one of those cleaning bots could get through."
Ooh...
Boink! Go go go, little buddy. Okay. See ya!
Whoa, can I follow? Oh shit. Alrighty then. That's a thing. OHHH...
Oh, you got it. Oh, thank you! Well that was easy. Okay. Thank you little buddy! Alright, thank you!
Hi-ya! Let me in. Bang. That's my key card right there, baby. Yeah, how you doing? You all right, buddy? Hey.
Hey come on now.
Hey cheer up. Good luck to ya- "... get this back to the teleporter." Alright, okay,
well if it's that easy then. Oh guess I'll do it oh, I guess I will all right. Here? Nah!
Oh, yeah, that looks teleporty. Hey do you need a part? Oh yeah you do, baby.
Balonk! Alright who wants some?
Anybody? You want some?
Come on.
"If I get into that transfer station," uh-huh- "an argent accumulator could overload the systems and destroy the portal." Uh-huh? Okay...
So uh- "We only built a few of the accumulators." Uh-huh... "Hacking into Hayden's computer is probably the best way to find one." Woo...
I don't know if he'd like that too much, but okay. I'll teleport there sure yeah, okay. Take me! Oh...
Welcome to the party.
I don't know if I'd like that that's a very soma esque and something tells me that that's not something I'm gonna particularly
Ooh... "We need to get into Hayden's office to find an accumulator."
Oh-ho Do I?
Okay. Something tells me. There's a bit of big trouble on the other side of this guy.
Whoa, where the heck did that come from? Ho!
Boink boink. Yes please. Ah!
Okay, I'm gonna get away from that guy. Just hit the damn explodies! I see 'em right there! There, buh- okay,
well, that did nothing for me. Can you just shoot him? Sheezums! Alright, that was panic inducing. Hello. What are you? Thank you.
What is thi- uh? Ooh...
Never mind. I'm not gonna question this gift from the gods. Hey you want some of this? Very overkill,
I know, but I had it and I had to use it.
Ooh. Ohh!
Yes, please baby. Oh, yes please. Alright. I need health,
desperately. Oh!
And you max it out. That's so kind of you!
Hello! Cole elevator. I have a feeling there's gonna be something in there. Ah! I have a feeling!
I just have a funky feeling in my funky brain.
Damn it! God, I'm the worst at that.
All right, you good? You good, titty sprinkles? You god damn piece of shit, alright.
That is not what I want to use on that control panel. There we go!
Boink!
Okay, alright. We are good. Who's ready to say hello to my big friend?
Uh?
Huh? OOH!
Okay. I'm gonna get this just because
my pistol seems like- since it has unlimited ammo,
it's probably gonna be something that I'm gonna be using a lot of so why not, am I right people?
That is underwhelming at best. Alright, whatever. Hey, Sammy boy!
Sammy boy!
"It's not like we just leave accumulators lying around."
Uh-huh... Ah.
Hello, sorry. Sorry sorry. I can't hit anything anyway, so it didn't do dick.
What do we got?
Hacking: a cursor moves back and forth on a roll letter. Stop the cursor by pulling the right trigger. It flashes green over a
letter and the cursor precedes to the next row. Complete all the rows to win the mini game. Win the mini game?! My
favorite thing! I don't know what's happening now. I don't know what's happen- okay.
*noises of confusion and realization*
Okay I get it I get it. (He doesn't get it)
*more confusion*
Okay I got it. "The last accumulator is in that prototype cyberdemon they lost."
Uhh... "Gotta get back to the OPS lab."
Do I have to kill the cyberdemon because I'm pretty sure I remember the cyberdemon already being
killed by me and another body, and I don't think, you know.
I don't think it's fair to the poor cyberdemon that has to deal with life,
you know, knowing it has to be embarrassed by two versions of myself.
Like that's just sad.
"... shouldn't be too far."
Uh- huh okay alright okay.
*joyful Markimoo singing*
oh hello
*more singing*
Ooh- ow!
Doodlee do!
There we go.
Got him. Oh, that's sure that- that's pretty good that charged shot is something good.
That's a slice of something special. Alright, come at me you bitch!
Oh yeah, I forgot I can't do that to that. Oh...
Alright.
Stop tick okay aw yes. Less ceremonious than I did before! Oh, that's not good. Hang on, I need to get my bigger gun!
This one.
Whoa. Hey. Alright, now we're getting into it. Hey, buddy. Ooh, no you don't. Oh, yeah, you miss. Nope,
I don't thinks- I- I don't think so
Oh, that ain't good. I don't DERARn so
mister!
Man, oh boy wait no. I'm gonna tela-  a god damn it!
Okay, alright, I had that in the ba- Oh, I have no hand. There I am apparently. Oh, there I am.
I'm sorry. I was facing the wrong way.
I had that in the bag on lockdown and it decided to be a piece of shit. Not me. Okay, I got this. No- ah!
Ah, not what I wanted. Hey! Oh, okay. Alright. THAT'S IMPORTANT!
Oh boy. Ow. Buddy, ow that hurts! Ow that- I said that hurts so that means I should get away from it, huh?
Ay, yai, yai. Oh god, that's-.This is a challenge! Oh god. Where? No! Oh god. Oh god. We're *sigh*.
Ah!
Okay. Uh uh uh uh...
This.That!
Oh there's two of you!
Oh god, oh! NO!
God that's tough. That is ridicu- okay why- why there? Okay.
That is really tough. Not a joke. Where am I? God. How?
All right, whatever. It's it's fine
Gotta stand my ground. I got this!
Come on!
Ow, god damn it right into that, oh boy. Got that guy!
Not you too. Whoa got him. Okay. I got him. I got him. I didn't know that I got him.
God damn.
Oh god damn it. Really? One health. Oh boy. Oh boy. Okay, god. God! That's annoying
That is really annoying the teleport mechanic is super not conducive to what we have like the- the
fast movement shit. I got this I got this I got this. God come on!
Come on. Alright, alright, alright I got this. Not that why? This shotgun is not what I want.
Why won't it go to the weapon wheel? Please! I'm begging you! Just why whoa?
How do I get the weapon wheel?!? Oh my god. Oh, that's so frustrating. That's so frustrating
The teleporter is super inconsistent. No! Not where I wanted to be.
No no weapon wheel weapon wheel! Weapon- ARE YOU FUCKING KIDDING ME?!?
There. The weapon wheel. I push
that button and
the weapon wheel. I have to press and then move. I get it okay.
Okay hang on wait. No don't- don't you fucking dare.
*Markiplier being a silent bad ass*
Alright now we're getting into something here
Okay, alright. Okay. Alright. Woah- okay. Well alright, then. Oh boy. Okay.
Oh that's not alright, woah. Okay, alright, I'm gonna end that there. That's it.
I could- wow. Okay, so at that difficulty, I can't do that. That is just a- an
impossibility at that particular difficulty so
that is all the time I have for this
I've actually been playing it more than I expected to so thank you everybody so much for watching. That was Doom VR.
The Doom experience is not right to translate to VR because the Doom experience is like
very minute controls that are very precise and the game feel is very important.
In VR, if you got really good at this, it would still be frustrating so it's- it's good. It's kind of fun but,
not worth the pain in your soul, so thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know we thought this down in the comments below and
uh, thanks again for watching. And as always I will see you in the next video
Bye-bye!
*Outro Music*